[Applaus]
ein Jahr nach dem Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges die Ukraine kämpfen
weiter gegen die Invasion und für ihre
Freiheit wir schauen auf wichtige
Ereignisse der vergangenen 365 Tage
Russland greift am frühen Morgen die
Ukraine an dafür hat Russland über
Monate Soldaten in Stellung gebracht
mindestens 30.000 Soldaten und schweres
Militärgerät hat Putin unter dem Vorwand
einer gemeinsamen Militärübung im
Vorfeld in Belarus stationiert
von dort aus sind es nur rund 100 km bis
in die ukrainische Hauptstadt Kiew
auch entlang der direkten
ukraine-russischen Grenze vom Norden bis
zum Süden sind mindestens 120.000
Soldaten positioniert und Russlands
Militär hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch
einiges mehr aufzubieten insgesamt
verfügt es über rund 850.000 Soldaten
und 250.000 Reservisten auf ukrainischer
Seite
200.000 Soldaten und eine ähnliche
Anzahl an Reservisten
viele russische Soldaten sind zu diesem
Zeitpunkt ganz im Süden auf der Krim im
Einsatz die seit 2014 annektierte
Halbinsel mit dem eisfreien
Schwarzmeerhafen Sebastopol ist für die
Russen strategisch wichtig
wirtschaftlich und militärisch
die Schwarzmeerflotte der Russen nutzt
im Krieg eine Seeblockade als
Druckmittel gegen die Ukraine monatelang
können ukrainische Güter wie Mais und
Weizen nicht verschifft werden
russische Truppen nehmen die
süd-ukrainische Gebietshauptstadt herson
ein die Großstadt liegt auf der
westlichen Seite des Flusses
die gesamte Region ist durch ihre Nähe
zur Krim bedeutsam erst im November
können die Ukrainer die russischen
Besatzer auf die Ostseite des Flusses
zurückdrängen und die Gebietshauptstadt
zurückerobern
etwa einen Monat nach Kriegsbeginn die
versuchte russische Einnahme der
Hauptstadt Kiew scheitert Moskau
verkündet sich auf den Don Bass zu
konzentrieren dazu gehören die Oblaste
also die Regionen donett und luansk
russische Separatisten kämpfen hier
schon seit 2014 gegen ukrainische
Soldaten
die russischen Truppen ziehen aus der
Region Kiew ab Benzin und auch
versorgungs-
Mutter ein Vorort von Kiew rund 35
Kilometer entfernt der Ort wird zum
Inbegriff der russischen
Gewaltbereitschaft mindestens 400
getötete Zivilisten werden hier gefunden
Kriegsverbrechen die Russland bestreitet
zurück in den Süden der ukrainischen
Armee gelingt ein schwerer Schlag gegen
Russland sie versenkt das größte
russische Kriegsschiff im Schwarzen Meer
die Moskwa ein Ersatz kann erstmal nicht
kommen die Türkei versperrt am Bosporus
die Zufahrt für Kriegsschiffe
Russland liegt am Asowschen Meer die
Stadt Mario Paul in Schutt und Asche im
Zentrum der Kämpfe eines der größten
Stahlwerke Europas
2500 im astorf Stahlwerk verschanzte
ukrainische Soldaten werden schließlich
in Kriegsgefangenschaft genommen
bis heute ist dieses Gebiet in
russischer Hand
im Sommer wird das ukrainische
Atomkraftwerk saporisha das größte
Atomkraftwerk Europas in die Kämpfe
einbezogen es ist für die
Energieversorgung weiter Teile des
Südens zentral wegen Beschuss und
Beschädigungen muss es immer wieder vom
Netz genommen werden das Risiko eines
nuklearen Unfalls latent Vertreter der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde sind
immer wieder vor Ort
monatelang verhindert Russland mit
seiner Seeblockade die Ausfuhr von
ukrainischem Getreide per Schiff mit
verheerenden Folgen besonders für viele
ärmere Länder Hunger droht Getreide und
rotpreise explodieren nach Verhandlungen
der Vereinten Nationen der Türkei und
Russlands fahren endlich wieder mit
Weizen Mais Sojabohnen oder
Sonnenblumenöl beladene Frachtschiffe in
die Welt
die Situation im Nordosten rakif ist die
zweitgrößte Stadt der Ukraine fast
eineinhalb Millionen Menschen leben hier
der Angriffskrieg löst eine riesige
Fluchtwelle aus
von den knapp 700.000 Menschen die
bleiben leben viele Monate lang in
U-Bahn-Schächten
schließlich hat die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive Erfolg doch auch nach dem
Rückzug der Russen liegt die grenznah
Stadt unter Dauerbeschuss das ganze
Gebiet um hakiff bleibt umkämpft und
russische Kämpfer erobern im Winter
immer wieder nahe Städte wie solle da
und bachmut
in Russland spricht Putin lange Zeit nur
von einer spezialoperation das Wort
Krieg darf nicht benutzt werden doch
auch die Russen merken dass der von
Putin propagierte Regimewechsel in der
Ukraine längst mehr ist am 21 september
verkündet Putin die Teilmobilmachung
mindestens 300.000 weitere Russen sollen
zum Militär
nach Schein Referenten annektiert
Russland neben den oblasten Donezk und
luhansk auch die beiden südlicher
gelegenen Regionen saporisha und herson
doch die Ukraine kämpft weiter um ihr
gesamtes Territorium gibt den Donbass
nicht auf und erobert auch im Süden
Gebiete zurück
der erbitterte ukrainische Widerstand
Drohnen Angriffe auf die krimbrücke und
auf Luftwaffenstützpunkte zum Teil weit
im Inneren Russlands machen klar längst
ist die Ukraine auch durch die
Waffenlieferungen anderer Länder zu
einem ernst zu nehmenden Gegner für
Russland geworden Russland ist nur
bereit für Friedensverhandlungen wenn
die Ukraine die russischen Realitäten
und damit die Annexionen akzeptiert die
Ukraine fordert nun weitere und bessere
Waffensysteme nicht nur zum Schutz der
Zivilbevölkerung auch zum Schutz ihrer
Truppen und für weitere Rückeroberungen
Frieden scheint in weiter Ferne
[Musik]